>> John: OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS
IT IS TIME TO ADAPT TO A NEW
NORMAL HAS THE COUNTRY CONFRONTS
THE REALITIES OF CORONAVIRUS AND
SAYS THERE IS A LONG ROAD AHEAD.
JOINING US NOW IS THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL DR. TOM FRIEDEN.
WILL COME BACK TO FOX NEWS
SUNDAY AND ON A PERSONAL LEVEL,
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
BOTH OF US WERE THERE, GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
SO LET ME ASK YOU FIRST OF ALL
READY YOU THINK WE ARE HEADING
WITH THIS WITH A NUMBER OF
INFECTIONS ARISING, WHERE ON THE
INFECTION CURVE ARE WE?
ARE WE EXPECTING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CASES IN THE NEXT
FEW DAYS AND WEEKS ARE WE
EXPECTING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CASES?
>> FIRST OFF, WE ARE IN
DIFFERENT PLACES IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE U.S. AND DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE WORLD AND THAT’S
WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT THAT STATE
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
GOVERNMENTS HAVE A KEY ROLE HERE
IN TRACKING WHAT’S HAPPENING
LOCALLY NOT ONLY WITH A VIRUS
BUT WITH THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
AND ADVISING PEOPLE ON WHAT TO
DO.
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY, WE ARE
TELLING EVERYONE STAY HOME.
AND IN NEW YORK CITY WHERE THE
HOSPITALS ARE GETTING
OVERWHELMED, SAYING IF YOU HAVE
MILD ILLNESS, DON’T GET TESTED.
IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE ANYTHING.
YOU GO OUT THERE TO GET TESTED,
YOU MAY USE UP TESTING SUPPLIES,
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT, EFFORT OF
THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND IF
YOU ARE NOT INFECTED, YOU MIGHT
GET INFECTED.
SO MILD ILLNESS, THEY STAY HOME.
WE WERE GOING FIRST OFF REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET ONE KEY
CONCEPT.
TAKES ON AVERAGE FIVE OR SIX
DAYS FROM THE TIME SOMEONE GETS
INFECTED TO WHEN THEY GET SICK
IN ABOUT ANOTHER WEEK BEFORE
THEY GET VERY SICK WITH A SEVERE
CASES WE ARE SEEING TODAY ARE
PEOPLE WHO WERE INFECTED TEN TO
14 DAYS AGO.
THAT MEANS FOR THE NEXT TEN TO
14 DAYS, WE ARE LIKELY TO
CONTINUE TO SEE A BIG INCREASE
IN CASES IN PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK CITY.
THAT’S WHY WE’RE WORRIED ABOUT
HEALTH CARE BEING OVERWHELMED
AND KEEPING THEIR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE.
>> John: SAYS THAT LOCKDOWNS
ARE NOT ENOUGH.
IN READING THE QUOTE FOR HIM,
SAYS WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON HIS FINDING THOSE WHO
ARE SICK, THOSE WHO HAVE THE
VIRUS AND ISOLATE THEM, FIND
THEIR CONTACTS AND ISOLATE THEM
BUT I WAS TALKING TO SOMEBODY AT
THE CDC JUST ON FRIDAY WHO TOLD
ME THAT THE CDC IS NOT DOING A
WHOLE LOT OF CONTACT RACING
ANYMORE BECAUSE NOW THE DISEASE
IS SO WIDESPREAD.
>> IT DEPENDS ON WHERE YOU ARE.
IN A PLACE LIKE NEW YORK CITY
WHERE WE HAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF INFECTIONS, MAY BE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS ALREADY, FINDING
THE SOURCES OF CASES AND THE
CONTEXT ISN’T GOING TO WORK BUT
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IS DRIVE
DOWN NEW INFECTIONS, STAY HOME,
WASH YOUR HANDS, DON’T SHAKE
HANDS, STAY 6 FEET AWAY FROM
EVERYONE AND THEN OVER THE NEXT
TWO TO THREE WEEKS, WE MIGHT
EXPECT TO SEE AFTER THAT STARTS
WITH A LACK OF A COUPLE OF WEEKS
FOR THE PREVIOUSLY INFECTED
PEOPLE DRIVE DOWN OF CASES AND
THAT’S WHEN YOU START WITH THE
AGGRESSIVE TESTING, CONTACT
RACING, ISOLATION AND TAMP DOWN
CASES ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY
AND IN THE WORLD WHERE PEOPLE
ARE COMING IN, ANYONE WHO IS
SICK, ISOLATE, ISOLATED AS THEY
BECOME SICK.
>> John: WE KNOW YOU HAVE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THAT AS
WELL IN THE EBOLA CRISIS A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO AS WELL, IN
TERMS OF A VACCINE, WE KNOW WE
ARE STILL A YEAR AWAY BUT THERE
IS SOME PROMISING THERAPIES THAT
SEEM TO BE ON THE HORIZON, ONE
OF THEM IS AN OLD FRIEND WHO WAS
USED AS AN ANTIMALARIAL AGENT
WENT TO VIETNAM DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR, HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE,
SOME EVIDENCE THAT IN
COMBINATION WITH A VERY COMMON
ANTIBIOTIC AZITHROMYCIN CAN
SHORTEN THE COURSE OF DISEASE
BUT IT SEEMS TO BE SOME DEBATE
OVER WHETHER OR NOT THAT SHOULD
BE DEPLOYED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP VERY BULLISH ON
IT, DR. ANTHONY FAUCI A LITTLE
MORE SUSPECT.
>> WE ARE TRYING TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN MAKING SOMETHING
WITH THE POTENTIAL OF AN ACTIVE
AND EFFECT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> I AM MORE OF A FAN OF THAT
THAN ANY BODY ELSE.
I’VE SEEN THINGS THAT ARE
IMPRESSIVE.
WE ARE GOING TO KNOW SOON
INCLUDING SAFETY.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT HAS
SAID WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
WE’VE GOT THIS DRUG THAT’S OUT
THERE, WE’VE KNOWN IT FOR ALMOST
70 YEARS NOW, DO YOU THINK IT
SHOULD BE TRIED, SHOULD IT BE
DEPLOYED?
>> WE ALL HOPE IT WILL BE GOOD
TREATMENT BECAUSE THAT WOULD
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
RECENTLY JUST LAST WEEK, TWO OF
THE BEST ANTIVIRAL DRUGS HAVE
BEEN IN COMBINATION AND DIDN’T
SHOW ANY IMPACT.
SO ABSOLUTELY I THINK WE SHOULD
URGENTLY FIGURE OUT WHETHER
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND
AZITHROMYCIN HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE OUTCOMES OF DISEASE.
WE HAVE THREE GOALS HERE.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF INFECTIONS,
IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVE AN INFECTION AND REDUCE
THE SOCIETAL AND ECONOMIC HARMS
OF THIS PANDEMIC.
>> John: YOU SAID THERE IS TOO
BIG STORIES COMING IN THE NEXT
WEEK, WHAT DO YOU SEE COMING
DOWN THE TRACKS?
>> SADLY IN PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK CITY, I’M AFRAID WE
WILL SEE AN INCREASE IN NUMBER
OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS INFECTED,
SOME OF WHOM MAKE IT SEVERELY
ILL AND THE POTENTIAL THAT WE
WILL OVERWHELM SOME OF OUR
INTENSIVE CARE CAPACITY.
THAT’S WHAT I’M MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT FOR THE COMING WEEK.
THE MODELS THAT WE’VE SEEN IN
THE TRENDS WE’RE SEEING ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNING.
I SAID IT’S ABOUT SEVEN OR TEN
OR 14 DAYS FROM THE TIME OF
INFECTION TO SEVERE ILLNESS.
THAT MEANS A SEVERE ILLNESS WE
ARE SEEING NOW WAS A RESULT OF
INFECTIONS THAT HAPPENED ALMOST
TWO WEEKS AGO AND IN THOSE LAST
TWO WEEKS, THERE’S BEEN AN
ESCALATING NUMBER OF CASES SO
THE POSSIBILITY OF HAVING
TREMENDOUS STRESS ON OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, NURSES AND
DOCTORS, TRANSPORTS, EVERYONE IN
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM THAN WITH
THAT MORE RISKS OF PATIENTS
DYING.
THAT’S VERY CONCERNING AND MY
NEW YORK CITY AND ELSEWHERE
PEOPLE ARE SCRAMBLING TO SCALE
UP THE CAPACITY TO CARE FOR
PATIENTS SAFELY BUT THAT’S NOT
EASY TO DO, THIS IS VERY
INVOLVED INTENSIVE CARE.
>> John: WE SAW YOU THERE IN
AFRICA AND ALL OF YOUR
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AS YOU ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT WAS GOING ON
WITH THE EBOLA CRISIS FIRST
HAND.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL HAS
BEEN SIDELINED SOMEWHAT IN THE
PUBLIC ASPECT OF THIS?
WE HAVEN’T SEEN DR. REDFIELD FOR
DAYS NOW.
>> AT THE TABLE, THEY ARE THE
LEADING HEALTH PROTECTION
AGENCY.
ONE OF THE CENTERS WITHIN THE
CDC IS THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR
IMMUNIZATION AND RESPIRATORY
DISEASE, THEY HAVE MORE THAN 700
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE
EXPERTS IN UNDERSTANDING CONTROL
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
AND IN ORDER TO DO MORE AND
PROTECT PEOPLE MORE, WE NEED
THEIR FULL INVOLVEMENT.
IN CENTRAL TO THE RESPONSES
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE AND IT IS
LIKE FIGHTING WITH ONE HAND TIED
BEHIND YOUR BACK.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT IS
GETTING HIGH MARKS FROM PEOPLE
LIKE GOVERNOR CUOMO OF NEW YORK
AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR WORKING
WITH THE STATES I’M TRYING TO
COMBAT THIS VIRUS.
YOU’VE BEEN WATCHING THERE FROM
HERE PERCH IN NEW YORK CITY WITH
THIS WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN DOING,
HOW WOULD YOU GRADE THE
PRESIDENT’S RESPONSE?
HE HAS BEEN CRITICIZED BY PEOPLE
AS WELL.
>> THIS IS NOT A TIME FOR
GRADING.
THIS IS A TIME FOR ALL OF US TO
WORK TOGETHER FOR EVERY PART OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
INDIVIDUALS, PEOPLE TO PULL
TOGETHER AGAINST A COMMON ENEMY.
A DANGEROUS MICROBE.
THERE IS SOMETHING EVERYONE CAN
DO, STAY HOME, WASH YOUR HANDS,
DON’T GO OUT OF YOUR SICK,
SOMETHING OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
NEEDS TO DO, PREPARE FOR
PATIENTS AND ALSO KEY PEOPLE WHO
NEED THEIR MEDICATIONS FOR
HYPERTENSION OR DIABETES OR
OTHER ILLNESSES, KEEP THEM SAFE
AND ON MEDICATIONS THROUGH
TELEMEDICINE MY REFILL
PRESCRIPTIONS, ALL OF US CAN
PLAY A ROLE IN ONE THING WE HAVE
TO DO MORE IS TO UNDERSTAND THIS
VIRUS AND HOW IT IS SPREADING
AND HOW TO CONTROL IT BETTER.
THE BETTER WE UNDERSTAND IT, THE
BETTER WE CAN PROTECT PEOPLE.
>> John: IF I CAN COME BACK TO
WHERE WE STARTED, DO YOU BELIEVE
WE WILL SEE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CASES FOR HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CASES HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES?
>> I THINK WE ALREADY HAVE MANY
TIMES MORE CASES THAN HAVE BEEN
DETECTED.
IN PLACES LIKE NEW YORK CITY, WE
ALREADY HAVE TENS OR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INFECTIONS.
THERE IS NO DOUBT FROM THE
INFORMATION WE ARE SEEING.
THE CHALLENGE IS WHAT CAN WE DO
TODAY THAT CAN SLOW DOWN THIS
EXPONENTIAL PHASE OF THE
INCREASE, THIS ACCELERATING
PANDEMIC AND THAT IS POSSIBLE BY
PEOPLE STAYING HOME, AVOIDING
SOCIAL CONTACT.
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER AND
WHAT EACH ONE OF US DOES CAN
PROTECT ALL OF US.
>> John: ONE REAL QUICK
QUESTION, ANY IDEA HOW LONG THIS
IS GOING TO LAST?
>> VERY HARD TO PREDICT WHAT’S
GOING TO HAPPEN, THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED IT NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE BUT WE DO HAVE BY WORKING
TOGETHER THE ABILITY TO CHANGE
THE TRAJECTORY OF THIS PANDEMIC.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE COMING
MONTHS WILL TELL, BUT WHAT WE DO
IS WITHIN OUR POWER.
>> John: ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE